all is quiet at the facility where
scp-1027 floats in its containment
chamber the scp does not seem to react
as a guard opens the door to its room
the agent gropes for the light switch he
is new to the scp foundation and this is
his first night working on his own harsh
fluorescent light fills the room the
guard lets out a yelp when he sees
scp-1027 for the first time unable to
control his curiosity the guard
approaches the containment chamber
scp-1027 looks like a human nervous
system that has been extracted from its
body the brain eyes and connected nerves
are all exposed as if some mad doctor
perfectly dissected a human scp-10
does not move gross the guard thinks as
he taps on the glass casing with his
rifle he jumps back slightly in surprise
it seemed as if the eyeball had twitched
slightly to look at him so creepy the
guard says out loud he turns around to
exit the room as he approaches the door
the lights flicker he begins to walk a
little quicker suddenly the lights go
out completely plunging the room into
darkness a moment later the hum of the
fluorescence resumes as the lights come
back to life the guard slowly pivots to
look at the containment chamber
scp-1027 still floats motionless in its
sailing solution the guard sighs and
chuckles to himself for getting spooked
he turns and walks out of the room
closing the door behind him he makes it
a few steps down the hallway before
stopping the guard smacks his forehead
with the palm of his hand i forgot to
turn off the damn light he says he heads
back to the room
scp-1027 is contained in he reaches his
hand out to grab the doorknob it is warm
to the touch the guard turns it and
pushes the door open a scream gets
caught in his throat and only a slight
wheeze escapes his lungs standing in
front of him is scp-1027
the nervous system seems to pulsate as
it reaches its arms out towards the
guard who is paralyzed with fear the
guard feels a slight twinge in his ear
as a series of nerves enter his auditory
canal then he hears a voice inside of
his head it's his own voice and it's
telling him to escape his body the next
morning scp agents and scientists
returned to the site for another day's
work one scientist is surprised to find
the door to
scp-1027's room wide open he steps in
and looks around
scp-1027 floats motionless inside of its
saline containment chamber the scientist
shrugs turns off the light and closes
the door later that day a feeding team
enters
scp-1027's room pushing a cart with a
brain of a cow on top of it the three
members of the group are wearing level
four bioprotective equipment they enter
the room and secure the door behind them
one of the men walks over to the
containment chamber and pushes a few
buttons as the liquid in the tube slowly
begins to drain
scp-1027 drops down into a laying
position on the examination table below
it when the water is completely gone the
glass tube hisses open a moment later
scp-1027 sits up it looks about the room
with its exposed eyeballs its nerves
wriggle like tiny worms as they sense
the world around them
scp-1027 rotates its body so it's
sitting with its legs over the side of
the table the feeding team tries to
remain calm but seeing a nervous system
move without an actual body is a bit
disconcerting to say the least
researchers found that
scp-1027 was able to survive without the
protective casing of muscles and skin
because each nerve cell is surrounded by
myelin sheathing 300 times thicker than
that of normal human cells the scp
slowly slides off the table and proceeds
towards the cow brain that has been
placed in the middle of the room the
feeding team backs as far away from the
scp as possible until their bodies are
pressed up against the wall scp
researchers told them that the
containment suits would protect them
from 1027 but these same researchers
have been wrong before
scp-1027 stands next to the cow brain
and looks down at it normally at this
point
scp-1027 would extend its nerves and
wrap them around the bovine brain there
would be a slight pulsing and the brain
would begin to denature it is still
unclear if scp-1027 consumes the actual
brain matter or just feeds on the
residual chemical energy that resides in
the tissue the feeding team carries out
this procedure once a week which seems
to keep
scp-1027 happy but this time scp-1020
just stares at the brain as if it is
contemplating whether it is worth eating
it is almost as if
scp-1027 isn't hungry as if it is
already eaten but the team knows that's
crazy as they are the only ones who feed
this scp and it has been exactly a week
since its previous meal the feeding team
turned their heads to look at one
another through the clear face shields
in their suits one of the men shrugs as
they all turned back to watch what
scp-1027 does next the scp lifts its
head so that its eyes are looking
straight at the feeding team one of the
members reaches behind him searching for
the doorknob then
scp-1027 slowly turns around and walks
back towards the table it lays down and
goes still someone needs to lock it back
in its containment chamber one of the
men says that's jerry's job responds
another as he pushes the man next to him
towards where scp-1020 is laying alright
fine i'll do it but if that thing eats
me and turns me into an scp you two will
be the first people i go after jerry
walks slowly towards the containment
chamber he stretches his arm as far as
it will go to keep as much distance as
possible between his body and
scp-1027 jerry pushes a big red button
and the glass tube hisses close the
containment chamber fills with saline
water and
scp-1027 is once again suspended in the
liquid-filled tube the research team
grabs the cart with a cow brain on it
and rushes out of the room slamming the
door behind them they informed the head
of the facility of the odd behavior as
cp 1027 had exhibited but he is a busy
man and shrugs it off as just an anomaly
i don't eat when it's hungry enough give
it a week and then try again the
facility commander tells the men the
feeding team walks silently down the
hall to the decontamination room where
they will take off their suits and
shower as a precaution to prevent the
spread of any foreign agents the
peculiar behavior of
scp-1027 lingers in their minds they
enter the room and begin to joke with
one another to ease their nerves this
makes them feel better it is silly to
worry about scp-1027 now that it is
safely contained in its chamber once
again they turn the shower heads on and
steam slowly fills the room i might call
out sick next week just to be safe that
scp is going to be really hungry after
missing its meal this week and i don't
want to become a snack one of the men
says as he scrubs his body yeah that's
not a bad idea responds jury who knows
what the creepy thing will do if it ever
gets out of its containment chamber
maybe it'll eat our brains although
there wouldn't be much seed in your case
bob
he says pointing to his teammate the
whole team laughs as the room continues
to fill with steam jerry's smile slowly
fades as he feels something tickle his
ear he uses his hand to brush whatever
it was away but the sensation comes back
jerry washes the soap from his face and
turns around all he can see is steam hey
you guys stop messing around jerry yells
what are you talking about jerry one of
the other members of the team asks jerry
sees the steam move directly in front of
him he rubs his eyes to help him focus
through the moisture when he takes his
hands away an instance of
scp-1027 is standing directly in front
of him he is staring straight into the
eyeballs of the nervous system of the
guard who had entered
scp-1027's room the previous night what
the but before jerry can finish his
sentence the instance of scp-1027 shoves
its nerves down jerry's throat silencing
his voice it then sticks the nerves of
its hand into jerry's ear the scp-1027
instance feels around in jerry's head
until it locates the part of the brain
it is looking for and connects to it
jerry's brain is flooded with dopamine
and chemical signals are transferred
from the scp-1027 instance directly into
its victim's brain jerry's nervous
system now wants to break free of the
flesh casing that contains it jerry you
okay over there asks bob you've gone
yeah kind of quiet but there is no
response jerry's nervous system moves
his body towards one of the shower knobs
and turns the hot water on full blast
it's hoping that if the water is hot
enough it will scald the skin and muscle
tissue making it easier to remove from
the body
jerry the other team member says
suddenly the steam shifts and the
scp-1027 instance is standing in the
middle of the shower room the remaining
members of the feeding team scream in
horror they try to escape but slip on
the wet shower floor
scp-1027 slowly approaches them with its
nerves outstretched the echoing shouts
from the feeding team are muffled as a
series of nerves enter their bodies the
day continues at the scp site as if
everything was normal agents are
debriefed on previous missions
scientists experiment on different scps
and administrators meet to plan the next
acquisition the sun begins to set and
people start to leave for the day all is
quiet that night as a new security guard
makes his rounds the guard that the
administrator of the facility had just
hired disappeared without a trace the
night before his disappearance was
chalked up to nerves and being too
scared to return to work the new guard
checks each room to make sure everything
is secure he approaches the room that
contains scp-1027
he opens the door flicks on the light
and looks at the scp floating in its
containment tube gross the guard says
out loud he flicks off the light and
continues his rounds near the far part
of the hallway the door to the
decontamination room is slightly ajar
the guard approaches and pushes it open
with his night stick he takes one step
into the darkness and feels the wall for
the light switch he turns the lights on
there is nothing but a wet floor the
guard shrugs and turns off the lights he
walks through the doorway
as he steps back into the hallway he is
greeted by four instances of scp-1027
the guard opens his mouth to scream as
the nervous systems reach out their
tendrils and plunge them into his ears
nose and mouth now watch
scp-1548 the star the hateful scp
animation or check out scp-001 the
children or boro cycle scp animation